the Joe Rogan experience do you spend
any time meditating I do I'm not
particularly effective at it and so most
people are that way yeah you know um but
you know years ago effective ones well
years ago a friend of mine bought me one
of these transcendental meditation
courses and I was like okay I'll just
try it he BC he spent the money I'm
gonna actually go and do it and it was
kind of eye-opening there was a lot of
what you might call woo woo stuff that
was happening in the lectures and in
fact the funny thing is the guy given
the lecture he did recognize me and you
could I could tell how uncomfortable he
was giving his normal description
because he kept looking at me sheepishly
as he would invoke quantum physics and
things of that you know but I was I told
my dude you know whatever this I'm not
here to judge you I'm just here to sort
of see what's going on but the idea of
allowing the mind to be in a different
mode of operation which is sort of how I
summarized the experience you know if
you're if you're reciting the mantra in
your mind and allowing that to be a sort
of pedal point a driver of how your mind
is behaving at that moment that's a very
different way of being in the world from
thinking about grocery shopping or
solving Einstein's equations and I think
that to me is the the value of it it's a
systematic way to put your mind in a
different mode of operation and at times
I find it very useful to move into that
place hmm what when when you started
doing Transcendental Meditation what
about it was weird well what was weird
number one was doing this in this in
this group setting which is how you
start on this course and moreover it
being framed in a manner that I had
trouble aligning with my understanding
of how the world works by virtue of the
lectures that were given to us for what
it is what we were doing but through the
practice I sort of found I'm sure I'm
just translating from what they were
saying in the lecture into a language
that I'm more comfortable with and that
made it less weird for me because like
what you're talking about
religion just kind of cutting out the
thing cutting out the thing that didn't
make any sense to me and saying hey what
is this really about what this really is
about is breaking the usual chain of
thought that is 99.9% of the time of how
I live in the world and allowing my
brain to have a chain of thought that is
artificial because I'm sitting here
forcing myself to recite this mantra
inside my mind but that's a very useful
way of being because it's unfamiliar and
it's novel and it allows my brain to
operate in a different way so when I
translated it into that language it all
of a sudden made a lot more sense to me
and became not weird at all it became an
interesting practice and do you still do
it I do it when I feel I need it so
either friends of mine who say I cannot
live in the world if I don't do my 20
minutes in the morning simply you know
that that's part of my routine I don't
feel that way but there are moments when
I say whoa I need to do it and based on
circumstance based on what's happening
in a given moment it allows a kind of
mental reset if that's a language that
makes sense and that reset I consider to
be a valuable thing to do now should you
do you do do you do this I do I don't do
TM yeah but I do meditate and a regular
basis yeah a regular basis and I also
have a float tank yeah oh you don't use
really like a deprivation yeah yeah in
this building yeah it's right over there
I'll show it to you after we're done Wow
yeah can I do it sure you could have you
done I've never done it before I find it
a little bit terrifying
ummm same I do yeah there's plenty of
them there's a bunch of different float
place it's not terrifying at all really
yeah you just float relax and but it's
complete darkness oh yeah yes because I
have the little I have some
claustrophobia yeah and that's like for
instance I can't go into an MRI machine
oh really
yeah yeah totally I'm smart why don't
you get that out of your head I tried I
gotta tell you I trained so I have a
desk in my office where it's only about
like one foot high and I'd slide my body
underneath the desk clock the dork isn't
too weird and I'd stay under there as
long as I possibly could just long right
myself like 15 20
but I get into the real machine and
really yeah my wife's mom was like that
yeah like she did an MRI and she's like
it was the worst experience of my wifemy
I did two of them last week I fell
asleep I totally understand her I
thought really yeah I don't understand
why someone as smart as you would not
recognize well there's just less thing
around me and I do I do but it's it's
like the irrational part of being I get
in there my heart starts to pound when I
think that comes from I don't know it
cuz it wasn't always there and in it and
it has gotten worse in certains there
was a time again it's gonna I'm gonna
Karl I'm gonna come across like a
nutcase it was that trip to Amsterdam
now there's actually times when I
couldn't even go in a tunnel in a car
the claudia was that bad really
yeah I was in a taxicab I had to go to
New Jersey you know in Manhattan so I
had to take a Lincoln Tunnel and as the
taxis approaching Tunnel I said to the
guy I can't do it I can't do it
and the guy says boy I can't let you out
it's illegal to let you out I said you
got to let me out I can't do it and I
just opened the door and it got out oh
my god that's so crazy but now I'm fine
with tunnels so I don't I don't know
what it is that that maybe you're too
small senshu ated it there maybe you too
so yeah and maybe you're a is playing
tricks with you and giving you anxiety
to sort of shake it up the world and
yeah maybe you're maybe kind of only
contemplating the gigantea picture yeah
actual scope of the universe and yeah
but now I'm pretty stable about these
things so it's just MRI machine so it's
really close into your but you gotta
just do a lot of MRIs you know exactly
I'm sure that would do it that would
absolutely do probably right if you have
MRIs on a regular basis then I'm sure
you get used to it but yeah I just I
just do a real simple type of meditation
when I probably eventually gonna take a
TM course cuz my friend Tom Papa he's
really into TM and he raves about it
yeah but I just sit down and I breathe I
just concentrate only on my breath and I
it comes and goes but I concentrated
only on my breath and I find really good
relief from that Yoga is the same thing
I do yoga I tried to do it at least
twice a week when I like it yeah that
there's a lot of benefit in that in the
same way in that it's so difficult and
in the poses if you can only concentrate
on your breath just bow
and concentrate on your breath you'll be
filled with activity enough with the
with things to concentrate on with the
balancing of the posture and then the
breath that it acts as a almost brain
scouring it cleanses the mind of
unnecessary anxiety and a lot of other
just I even do that for a long time
yes sir I know yoga's been I've been
pretty steady for the last four years
right right and my wife does a lot of
yoga she keeps telling me that I need to
do it it's great you know it's great
it's great for the body as well and I
think the more comfortable your body is
the better your at least for me better
my mind got
[Applause]